oh High School am I right so many
emotions so little time and if you went
to high school when I did you probably
wore your backpack down to your thighs
and I actually still have marks from it
I mean textbooks were like a jillion
pounds anyways I digress everyone has or
will quote come of age so a well done
coming-of-age story always hits pretty
close to home and there's some really
good ones so get out your yearbooks and
take a look at you know all the drawings
you made over old what's his name and
what's her face while we bring you the
best high school movies all ranked by
Tomato Meter right now on Rotten
Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
starting off with one of my favorites
number 10 Carrie this horror flick was
actually released in 1976 and not only
is it the first ever Stephen King book
adaptation it was his first published
novel and as I'm sure you know there's
been over a hundred TV and movie out of
of his work since so not a bad way to
set the tone Spacek stars is carry
a withdrawn and sensitive 16 year old
who's bullied at school and abused by
her mother at home she begins to suspect
that she has Supernatural Powers which
isn't a good sign for her classmates
that invited her to prom and then played
a huge prank on her setting up one of
the most memorable scenes in movie
history you know the one
I mean that was basically my reaction
when the guy wanted to go to promway
that went with someone else how dare he
Susie actually ended up picking up a
Best Actress Oscar nomination for her
performance while Piper Laurie who
played her mom was nominated for
supporting actress and not only has the
prom scene been singled out as one of
the scariest movie moments ever coming
in at number eight during a 2004 Bravo
special it's even mentioned in the
critics consensus for this certified
fresh classic which says quote Carrie is
a horrifying look at Supernatural Powers
High School cruelty and teen angst and
it brings us one of the most memorable
and disturbing prom scenes in history
number nine Back to the Future
it actually wasn't easy for director
Robert zemeckis and screenwriter Bob
Gale to get this idea sold in Hollywood
which is crazy to think about
considering it is literally at the top
of most people's favorite movie list of
all time it actually took one of the
faces on the Mount Rushmore of Cinema
Steven Spielberg agreeing to produce it
under his newly formed amblin
entertainment to seal the deal I mean
what would our American cinematic
history even be without that man I don't
want to think about it so in the movie
Michael J fox plays high schooler Marty
McFly living his best life in 1985 until
he's accidentally sent back to 1955 in a
time machine created by his scientist
friend Emmett Doc Brown or he kind of
sort of has a crush on his mom it's
weird but stick with me here I mean who
knew all you needed was a flux capacitor
some plutonium and 88 miles per hour
believe it or not while Fox was the
first choice for Marty he actually
wasn't available and Eric Stoltz was
cast and even filmed some stuff
eventually Robert zemeckis realized that
Eric wasn't right and fought harder to
get Michael J fox who was popular on the
show Family Ties at the time the result
is a movie that is widely considered
like I said one of the best of all time
becoming the highest grossing film of
1985 worldwide and winning a handful of
awards
number eight Juno this 2007 Coming of
Age dramedy Stars Elliot page as the
title character a teenager dealing with
an unplanned pregnancy with her
boyfriend played by Michael Sarah these
Stellar cast also includes folks like
Jason Bateman Jennifer Garner Allison
Janney JK Simmons and of course Rayne
Wilson as a convenience store clerk
Juno was directed by Jason breitman son
of Ivan and written by Diablo Cody who
based much of it on her own high school
experiences and those close to her and
BT dubbed she actually wrote it while
sitting in a Target Starbucks in
Minnesota I mean how she managed to stay
out of the dollar spot is beyond me and
sure enough the Target Starbucks field
script actually won an Oscar for best
original screenplay while the film got
nominations for Best Picture best
director and best actress for Paige who
is presenting his female at the time
number 7 The Edge of Seventeen
this 2016 dramedy Stars Haley Seinfeld
as a High School junior already in the
throes of awkwardness as we all know
whose older brother starts dating her
best friend yikes this is literally my
worst nightmare luckily she strikes up a
friendship with a nice guy played by
Hayden Sito and while things are still
awkward with him it's actually more in
the good kind of way
the film was written and directed by
Kelly Freeman Craig in her directorial
debut and it also features names like
Woody Harrelson keyword Cedric and
Hayley Lou Richardson who I mean I just
love in the White Lotus season two and
if you're looking for a feel-good story
behind the story Craig actually sent a
copy of her script to Legendary producer
James L Brooks on a whim and he ended up
taking on the project anyways the edger
17 became a film festival darling for
the year and it actually still holds a
strong 83 audience score for over 25
000 ratings
number six American Graffiti
before he got busy making some random
space Western thing director George
Lucas actually got behind a camera for
this coming of age dramedy which was
produced by Francis Ford Coppola the
script was co-written by George as well
who uses early 1960s High School
experiences cruising around Modesto
California as inspiration the movie
stars Hollywood stalwarts Like Richard
Dreyfus and Ron Howard and it even
features one of Harrison Ford's first
major film appearances
hmm I wonder if he and George ever ended
up working together again
graffiti was a huge like ginormous hit
earning an Oscar Nam for Best Picture
plus after it was produced for just
under 800 000 it has become one of the
most profitable films ever between box
office and Home Video returns plus it
holds an important place in cinematic
history as the critics consensus so
rightfully points out calling it one of
the most influential of all teen films
as a Bittersweet look at a group of
recent High School grads last days of
Innocence
and look at that my friends we are
halfway there all right well now is
absolutely no time for senioritis
because we've got five more to go so
let's do this
number five book smart
this 2019 film stars Caitlin Dever and
beanie feldstein is two High School
academic Superstars trying to cram four
years of fun into one night before
graduating now the film immediately
takes you to a high school experience
that is just truly all too familiar yet
you also just kind of want to go there
too thanks to a stellar Supporting Cast
that includes Jessica Williams who we
love on shrinking and Jason Sudeikis
this actually marked the directorial
debut of Olivia Wilde who picked up the
independent Spirit Award for best first
feature meanwhile beanie feldstein
actually picked up a Golden Globe
nomination for her performance
number four Hairspray
this 1988 film was a bit of a departure
for writer director John Waters
considering that most of his earlier
movies were actually rated X aiming for
a broader audience with a PG rating
hairspray is set in 1962 Baltimore where
a high schooler played by Ricky Lake
rallies against segregation and seeks
Fame as a self-proclaimed pleasantly
plump dancer on a local TV show
despite six independent Spirit Award
nominations and consideration for the
grand jury prize at Sundance its initial
run in theaters actually didn't do much
however as you may already know the
movie became a cult classic thanks to
the Home Video era in the early 90s
number three say anything this 1989 teen
rom-com was written and directed by
Cameron Crowe in its feature directorial
debut it stars John Cusack as an average
student who has a romance with the class
valedictorian played by ioni Skye and if
I can say anything about this film I'm
so clever it's that it has one of the
most famous and culturally significant
scenes in U.S movie history I'm getting
excited just thinking about it you know
what Shane I'm talking about the giant
Boombox Peter Gabriel's in your eyes and
a guy who's got good endurance in his
arm muscles I mean I would have been so
tired holding this thing up
this iconic scene is my actual dream
wedding proposal fun fact Crow and
producer James L Brooks knew that this
scene would be iconic and originally had
a different song in mind Fishbone's
question of life but Crow later opted
for Gabriel's track to better fit the
mood
number two ladybird this film stars
Saoirse Ronan as a high school senior
dealing with an eventful final year in
school and also a loving but complicated
relationship with her mom played by
Laurie Metcalf
the movie was written and directed by
the gretiger wig in her solo directorial
debut and It ultimately put her on the
filmmaking map with Oscar nominations
for Best Picture directing and
screenplay but I gotta say not surprised
now Gerwig gave the cast and crew her
old high school yearbooks photos
journals and she even took them on a
tour of her hometown of Sacramento in
preparation for the film meanwhile cersa
actually dyed her hair red for the role
and didn't wear makeup to cover up her
acne in an attempt to quote actually
look like a teenager's face in real life
and get this the Irish actress also used
memories of watching Saved by the Bell
as a young girl to draw inspiration from
for her American High School scenes
okay my friends finally number one The
Last Picture Show this 100 certified
fresh drama from 1971 Stars Timothy
Bottoms and Jeff Bridges as high school
seniors and in 1950s Texas town the two
are contemplating their very different
Futures while one is having an affair
with the coach's wife and the other is
dating a local Beauty played by Sybil
Shepard
the film was directed and co-written by
Peter bogdanovich and adapted from the
semi-autobiographical 1966 novel of the
same name by Larry mcmurty it was
actually a house guest of Peters at the
time one Orson Welles who reinforced the
idea of shooting this movie in black and
white which wasn't super common at that
point in the 70s another unique feature
was the diegetic music meaning it was
all part of the actual scenes and the
actors were aware with Hank Williams Jr
being one of the main voices heard and
it all added up to a huge success both
at the box office and at the Oscars
where I earned eight nominations
including best picture and Best Director
while Ben Johnson and Cloris Leachman
both won best supporting actor Awards
plus it was ranked as one of the top 20
best high school movies ever by
Entertainment Weekly in 2008. the year I
graduated high school alright my friends
there you have it from an official prom
queen herself truly it was all downhill
from there for me but for more on all
these movies that we discussed us today
be sure to hit up rottentomatoes.com
thank you so much for checking out
today's list until next time I'm your
prom queen and host Naz Perez we'll see
you back here for more Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
[Music]